welcome I'm so happy to see some money
of you here I know there's a lot of
awesome sessions going on at the same
time so I'm very happy I'm humbled that
you chose mine so do you remember your
first computer do you remember those
first lines of code you wrote and they
compiled or perhaps they didn't compile
my first computer was the static
spectrum did anybody have one of these
no life is filled with defining moments
moments of realization when I got my
first computer I realized that I wanted
to become a developer these were my
first lines of code and I will share
this with you on on github if you want
them I think that many many developers
has these kinds of defining moments
moments when you when you realize that
you wanted to do this right this is
awesome this was code I wrote I made it
work now fast-forward to I believe this
was Bill 2015 I try the hololens for the
first time and i should ask how many of
you have tried the holland's before none
of you one awesome so I was letting to
room this was you have to put your
cameras and phones have to lock them in
you were not allowed to take pictures
and not nothing of that and with
learning into room where there was an
empty table so I put on the hololens and
and from that empty table a 3d model
gross it was house standing on that
table really really cool and then then
the guy said yeah so there's a computer
next to the table so I went to the
computer and he said up yeah yeah on
that screen you can do whatever you like
to that house on the screen and the same
thing will happen on the table so I took
the mouse and I dragged the heart and
the roof up and down and looking behold
the same thing happened on the tip on
the table I'm feeling my own table I was
really really amazed about this but I
also felt that why is this connected to
a computer why am I doing this here I
want to be here I'm gonna drag in the
house or standing on the table so the
guy said yeah so take the mouse pointer
drag it to the to the edge of the screen
and a little bit further and the mouse
pointer popped off the screen hovering
in mid air and I can manipulate
manipulate the house with that mouse
pointer so I ran back to Jessica my wife
I gotta tell you I couldn't even form
full sentences her mouse popped floating
air what are you talking about you don't
make sense
you know if listening floating air
pointer I was so amazed
so stood there this was the moment when
I realized that this technology is going
to be amazing this was the moment I
realized that this technologies will
basically change the world and this was
the moment that I realized that this is
something I really want to or actually
need to work with I call this the mouse
popping moment totally blew my mind and
it would happen once more and I will
come back to that in a little bit later
so what we're going to do today we're
gonna talk about the hololens hardware
we're gonna talk about basic unity stuff
how many I have used unity before how
many our unity experts usually that's
good yeah I'm not a unit expert by no
means
and we're gonna build our first
holographic app a really basic one the
goal of this session is to show you how
what what it takes to get started
writing your own holographic apps
my name is Jim angstrom and I'm a
Windows development MVP I have a normal
job if you will and on my spare time
around the company called awesome dev
together with my lovely wife and we
focus on future technologies so we we do
a lot of hololens we do a lot of UX and
stuff like that
we do a lot of BOTS and voice control
and we're on a a podcast called coding
after work
so if you want to check that out please
do but enough about me augmented reality
and basically means that you enhance the
reality right and this is new this is
really really new stuff when we research
this we realized that augmented reality
is actually the first time people talks
about something that we could could
relate virtual reality augmented reality
was 1584 1584 back then it was just in
written text 1862 we know that it was
actually used 1862 now what what it was
was it was a transparent piece of glass
and it was reflecting a room beneath so
you would actually get a spooky effect
but still it's augments the reality the
house enhances reality now hololens has
a couple of competitors one of them is
tomato and I want to try that one so
this one actually uses what what was
talked about 1862 this is called the
Pepper's Ghost effect
so this has screens in the top that
mirrors down into the visor so this uses
the technology from the 1500s
I think it's mind-blowing cool that
these olds technology is actually coming
back but augmented reality became a Fame
with pokémon go right
how many played Pokemon go so I had a
Windows Phone when this was popular so I
haven't but all the big companies want
to get in on this right so Apple
introduced something called a Ark it in
iOS 11 so that you can place 3d objects
in the real world Google has something
called tango so tango was needed to be
you had to have its own special hardware
just to work with now I bought one of
those weeks later Google says hey we
have something new we have a our core
this is something really cool you can
use whatever phone you like oh yeah and
Microsoft of course has something called
view mixed reality same thing ordinary
phone or tablet you can you can place 3d
objects in the real world but from my
perspective I don't believe that this is
where augmented reality is going to to
revolutionize the world I want to see
the real world not with my own eyes not
through a camera into screen into my
eyes so let's dive into the hololens
hardware i'm gonna talk about some of
the strengths the whole lens has and
some of the weaknesses to hololens has
because we need to know about these
things when we design our game or app so
Hollande's is the world's first
holographic computer
it's untethered which means that
everything computing power wise it has
the CPU everything is is in this tiny
little device the downside here is the
battery time I mean you actually have
batteries strapped to your head
officially the battery time is about 2
to 3 hours I would say it's actually
better than that depending on what you
do but you will definitely get three
solid hours out of this device I would
say three to four hours it's a really
good good device battery wise it has one
gigabytes of video memory it has 2
gigabytes of RAM it has 64 gigabytes of
storage it has Wi-Fi
it has bluetooth all the things that you
would imagine just in a normal computer
hat
it actually runs Windows 10 so this
means that you can run to the apps and
you can run 3d apps on this device so
all the things Universal Windows
platform applications all the things
that you can download in the Windows
Store is going to be run you can run
this on the hololens when it comes to
tracking I would say tracking tracking
is the thing that it's most amazing with
the hololens it has four environmental
sensing camera so cameras are that it's
filming the environment all the time it
has one depth camera and as I got one I
am you so inertial measurement unit so
gyro and stuff like that all that
combined will will make up the spatial
mapping so all this data is going to be
fed into the HPU the holographic
processing unit so all we're talking
about terabytes of data per second
I'm going to be pushed in into the HPU
this is Microsoft first and so far only
ship patents so this HBU is going to
crunch numbers and get Wow basically
where you are in the room that's all
it's gonna calculate and depending on
where you are in the room it's gonna
move around the Holograms and stuff like
that the lenses and uses something
called wave guides this is the same
technology that leap motion uses as well
so what it has it has the light emitter
in the top that bounces light into the
lenses through colored lenses and into
your eyes so this will kind of emulate
the way that light works so it's going
to bounce the light in the lenses as if
so this is real about it bad example
because black is basically omitting
light but imagine if this table was
white instead so the light is going to
bounce off this table and into my locker
ice that's how what light works so the
same way the light is going to bounce in
the lenses and bounce into my life into
my eyes as if there were some physical
object they're really really cool
technology now the bad side with that is
the feel of you there is cool thing is
that a lenses or transparency will see
the real world at the same time but the
field of view is kind of narrow you will
only see the the elephant in this case
like a little window it's gonna cut it
cut all sides and this is the same with
with leap motion it has a better feel of
you but remember the motion has two
years more development time than
hololens at this point so the next
tolerance I imagine is going to be even
more awesome
so to out how to avoid this is won't
make the Holograms smaller make sure
that they actually
fit into the feel of you the hololens
also have some kind of amazing speakers
these are called h h RTF so whole head
related transfer function so when we
hear something if i hear something from
my right here it's going to go into this
air a here and then it's gonna bounce
around and into this year
that's how sound works and the h RTF is
basically a bunch of algorithms that
takes all of this knowledge that we have
about sound and put them into the
software so if i just put something in a
audio source on my 3d object it's gonna
feel like it's actually going to bounce
around the room and get into my ears so
you will you will get to 360 degrees
really really good sound i'm amazed how
well this works another really cool
thing is that Microsoft has taken the
tracking technology and outsourced that
or actually let other companies use it
like Lenovo a sir HP and many others so
you have this mixed reality headsets
it's really confusing with a mixed
reality word or how they use it so I'm
not going to use this this is basically
VR headsets don't get fooled about it
this is a VR headset but you don't have
to have an external tracking so this
these headsets are using the the awesome
tracking technologies of the hololens
but in a VR world alright so we know
something about your hardware let's see
what we can actually use to develop for
it now we can use direct 3d how many
uses direct 3d a couple of you awesome I
think it's way too hard
you can actually use JavaScript you can
use unreal now I have a question mark
there because there is no official
support as far as I can see I I googled
for it
just yesterday to be sure that they
hadn't added it but there are some
country community contributions so you
actually will get a templates you get
can get started with unreal as well it's
something called or sharp so this
is a hora hora apparently means hero in
Finnish I hope I'm not butchering the
name and I would say it's pretty pretty
close to XNA has anyone tried XNA yeah
it's not a complete copy but but it
reminds you very much of what XNA used
to be I love this name and then you can
have unity but I think the last number I
heard was like 70 or 80 percent of all
the hololens apps that are in 3d
actually you actually made by unity so
made in unity so this is unity don't
worry we're gonna go into code in just a
couple of seconds so here we have tool
bar this is where we can change how we
can can move around the scene we can
change how big and small objects are we
have the scene so this is basically your
whole world so this is where you're
gonna put all the 3d objects you have
the hierarchy so by default you will get
a main camera you will get a directional
light in this case I have also added the
cube for dramatic effect or something we
have the project so this is going to
gonna mirror the hard drive so whatever
you have in this folder on your desk is
going to be shown here it's not like in
Visual Studio you can exclude things
whatever it is in here is going to be
shown here and then you have the
inspector so inspector is basically
property
if you if you're talking we should I say
sorry Mitchell student we should basic
but the dad come from
we should studio terms so there are a
couple of things that that are important
when it comes to the Holland's so the
first one is gays and I would go in a
little bit deeper into what these things
are
we have gestures voice sound and of
course spatial mapping so case is the
term gaze is often used when you talk
about eye tracking now this is not I
tracking this is basically basically a a
beam from your head straight out so you
need to move your head to actually move
the beam this is your mouse pointer if
you will now we have gestures so this is
going to be an air tap so the really
important thing is that you go from from
having your your finger vertically down
and then vertical again it's not that
sensitive but if you if you stay here
this is not probably not going to work
you have to be kind of specific in your
movements and it's when you have your
finger up again because this is going to
be a drag this is gonna be a hold pan so
you need to actually get your finger up
again you have the bloom gesture this is
gonna be like this so this is start menu
so you can show the start menu you can
quit your app you can hide it Start menu
you also have one of these clickers
let's see if I have one I do not have
one I actually borrow this whole and for
this talk I didn't bring my two to
Australia and so this a clicker is a
little small one it actually has a gyro
in it so you can actually scroll and pan
with it since this is a Bluetooth
enabled device you can use an Xbox one
s controller because those are the the
Bluetooth enable ones so let's see how
we can implement gestures to do that you
can actually do everything in unity but
the Microsoft has an open-source project
called mixed reality toolkit it's a
really really active community project
they do take pull requests all the time
I do this kinds of talks quite often and
basically every time I have to rewrite
my demos in a good way because they are
good changes so let's see how we can can
do this it's gonna go into unity I'm
gonna go into scenes and DC so this is
what you get when you create a new scene
you will get a main camera and a
directional light and I have to take my
sheet page so what I want to do is we
want to create a cube so we go here we
could create create a 3d object and we
create a cube now what we want to do is
we don't want to have a huge tube so
we're going to change the scale so
everything in unity is in meters so
point three meters is gonna be 30
centimeters
and we shall let's see we have a take
now we have a material there is I'm
gonna drag in my material so the box is
actually gonna become blue that's
scrolling so now we have a cube it's
blue and if we have any Doctor Who fans
that's a blue box now next up we are
going to use the mixed reality toolkit
so what I've done I have extract
actually downloaded the mixed reality
toolkit I have put it in the folder
that's it
and automatically you will get this
mixed reality to get menu so what I can
do is I can say that I want to apply
mixed reality project settings so here I
will get a couple of help I would get a
lot of help out of this so I can say I
want to target Windows Universal uvp
apps
I want to enable X R I want to build for
direct3d and enables sharing services
I'm gonna target included devices or the
colluded devices are those those VR how
VR visors are talked about and a couple
of more things actually all of the done
that so don't have to to clicked apply
but what I also want to do is I want to
choose configure and apply mixture of
the scene settings so this is important
so what this is going to do it's gonna
take my man it's going to replace my
camera with a mixed reality camera
prefab it's gonna move the camera to
origin so origin is going to be where my
head is at so Sara Sara Sara
if I move it's gonna move my the camera
in the scene that's how the hololens is
or actually how unity works it will add
a default cursor and I would come back
to that and it's gonna create an gonna
update world space
mrs. I um let's see here well I'm not
gonna add that now so let's see we're
gonna click apply I'm gonna scroll out
where's my cube I'm gonna change the
location of the cube so what I've done
the camera has moved to zero zero zero
the cube is going to be at my head
position but two meters in so it's gonna
be hovering midair about my height and
and two meters from me when I start the
application so if I start this yeah you
can see you can see those hands beneath
it so if I pray press shift I can
actually invoke clicking so this is
going to be the gestures doesn't matter
where I click because it's where I'm
looking at the object I'm looking at
that it's the one that is going to be
going you're going to get the action and
if I move move outside it's hard to see
here but it's a little dot right now and
a little bit it will become a circle if
I if I if I indicate that I want to do
something some gesture so let's see here
let's stop that one and so what I also
can do is I can go into I can select my
default cursor I can remove that and I
can go into holo toolkit input prefabs
cursor and I can select this interactive
mesh cursor instead I can just place it
in scene so if I run this instead you
will see that it's it's an add own --it
when
you're looking at something and it's a
dot when you're not looking at something
it will indicate that this thing is the
one that you're actually interacting
with so let's see here we can go to I
actually have a couple of scripts
prepared so we can go to my cube I can
add a component no I can't and I can
select cube select Handler and I want
the cube gaze handler let's take a look
at these scripts is it readable in the
back yeah awesome so these are really
really simple samples I'm gonna start
with saving the original color in this
case it's blue on focus enter so I'm
actually implementing the eye focusable
interface and I will get onfocus enter
so unfocus enter I'm gonna say that well
this cube is going to become red and
I'll focus exit I wanted to turn back
into this original color so this is when
I focus on the obvious want to look at
the object this should happen I also
have a another one called select handler
in this case I implement the I input
click handler interface I say that well
on input clicked I wanted to become
green instead so let's see if this
actually works
becomes red when I look at it if I look
away it's blue and if I click becomes
green and again doesn't matter where I
click because it's where I'm actually
focused that that is going to be invoked
awesome we've just implemented gaze and
we've implemented gestures it's just
that easy and it's no reason to not use
these technologies let's go back to
PowerPoint let's see what we did we
create a 3d object we create we change
the size of the food 3d object we added
a texture or exiting material and to to
create our first hologram we download
and mix reality took it well I didn't
show you that part
we applied scene settings we applied
product settings and we created a script
where we implemented eye focusable and a
script that implemented I input click
Handler and then we added those two
scripts to our cube now since I
mentioned this is say Windows 10 device
Cortana is available how many uses
Cortana a couple of you awesome so
Cortana for those who doesn't know is
when is Microsoft's voice assistant and
it's actually really good almost
everything in hololens can be controlled
by voice so select or uninstall or
closed so stuff like that
it's actually implemented in the
operating system itself and when it
comes to - holographic apps it's really
important thing to use your voice
because the alternative is to have
buttons all over the the
the world and that's not good that's
gonna take away from the experience so
actually using your voice saying
something to to the character in the
game for example or invoking commands
for for some other things it's really
really important so voice is a big part
of this let's see what it takes to
implement voice oh I have a little case
of OCD so I want to create a game empty
game object I'm gonna call it managers
don't have to do that but I need
managers I want to add a component
it's called speech speech input source
so this is all the keywords I want my
app to listen to so I want my app to
listen to a specific keyword I'm gonna
call it drop cube I'm also gonna add a
shortcut it's not always that my
computer actually understands me so I'm
gonna add it shirt cut as well so this
this makes it possible for my
application to even listen to this
keyword next up I want to go to my cube
I'm gonna add speech input onblur so
these are all built into the mixed
reality toolkit so what I can do is I
can create a new key word or I can say
listen to this key word I wanted to
listen to the drop cube key word I'm
gonna drag in a script called cube drop
to my cube like so and what I will show
you just in just a minute and as soon I
say this come on I wanted to actually
run in the editor and in runtime I
wanted to be
let's see here can I do it like this
instead maybe I want it to be this cube
object and I wanted to run the cube drop
drop cube and come on
so if we shake this this code so what it
does is it's going to check the smile
object have a rigid body so rigid body
is when when the object is going to be
affected by gravitation so if it doesn't
have one I want to add a rigid body if
it does have one but I wanted to wake it
up and I also have added that I'm gonna
check for R so reset so I'm gonna get
the rigid body I'm going to put it to
sleep and I'm going to to change the
position back to zero zero two so let's
see if we just run this yes
right so the question is why am i
switching between visual studio and
unity and so unity has does compile all
the code so it's it's mono in in the
backend and we should studio is the best
editor that I know for c-sharp code I
could use vs code if I like I think
nowadays it actually comes with visual
studio we need money install unity we'll
get to the community edition I believe
and earlier it was the mono develop a
thing yeah but at this point in time
these files are just files on discs
these are just see c-sharp files so I
can yeah heck I can use notepad if I
want so let's see if this works
drop cube and it dropped awesome
see if I can see what good oh just one
oh there it is I saw it there it is so
when I run this as you can see there is
some kind of imaginary floor and my cube
landed on that floor let's go back to
the presentation thank you
so what we did we added a speech input
source we added the keyword drop cube in
this case we added a speech input
handler to our cube we added our drop
cube script with basically just added a
rigidbody and we mapped the keyword to a
method that's all it takes now we
actually have voice controlled in our
app as well so next demo is going to be
audio now I mentioned the HRT F audio so
I'm not gonna be able to actually
visualize that completely but what you
should do is that if you're going to
edit preference no sorry not there I'm
going to go into project settings audio
and make sure that it actually uses Mr
MS HRT of spatial Iser so what I can do
is that I can now this is one of my
favorite features with unity I really
love this because again on my OCD as you
can see there's no audio source on this
object at this point so what I can do is
I can grab my cube audio I add that to
my cube and it's automatic automatically
gonna add an audio source
we want to select where is it there
spatialize on our audio source and we're
gonna check out the code so the reason
for the audio source to be added
automatically is that require component
row so I'm actually saying that to be
able to have this script I demand that
you have an audio source if you already
have one fine if you don't have have one
I'm gonna add that for you so what this
is going to do is I'm triggered enter is
an event that is going to be triggered
as soon as a Collider it's going to hit
your cube in anyway and then I want you
to just play the audio source and I'm
just gonna say I just wanted to be
played played once if we go back so if I
just so I have a box Collider so the box
Collider is thing that makes the cube
stay on the floor now for it to be
triggered to trigger this on triggered
event I need to to add this is trigger
this is going to make all the scripts on
the cube that has this event on it is
going to trigger the on on triggered
event now the problem with this is that
if I do that it's only gonna trigger
it's not gonna it's not going to stay on
the floor anymore so I actually need two
box colliders I need to add another one
I'm gonna add a component I'm gonna add
a box Collider
and as you can see the Box kaleidos size
is 0.9999 so it's it's a little bit
smaller and if you check the other one
it's one so what's going to happen is
it's when the box false or the cube
false it's gonna hit the first Collider
that which is the trigger one trigger
the sound and then stay on the surface
let's see if I'm if I'm not if I'm lying
drop cube
I know why but you also need to do is
actually add the sound so we add the
audio clip as well so let's see if this
works
ah and you need to remove play on wait
so let's see now drop cube
why don't you make any sound let's see
we have the box Collider
it's one it is trigger oh right so in
when you're doing this in the in the
editor
the interactive mesh actually and it's
created let's see if I can there is it's
actually created the floor quad for days
to actually happen in the editor I need
to make sure that the mesh Collider on
this is convex when you actually run
this in in the real world if you call it
that it will just work fine so let's set
try this drop cube and I have to look at
the cube
let me do that like this games so the
floor quad convex drop cube there it is
so what we did was we added we talked
about the required component freely I
really like I was so happy when I found
that keyword we said specialize on the
game object and all the audio source we
made sure that a product setting an
audio was MSH RTF spatialize ER
so now it comes to never now we come to
the last part the spatial mapping Lowe's
kitchen designer how have you heard
about this no awesome so Lowe's kitchen
designer uses the hololens to design
your own kitchens so the really cool
part is that they integrate this with
pinterest so you're at home pinning your
pic in your favorite kitchens I want
that one that one doesn't have to be
Lowe's kitchens and the take all of this
data run it through Asha cognitive
services to find the best matching
kitchen in the Lowe's kitchen repertoire
so you go into the store I said BJ I
would like to buy a kitchen and this is
my Pinterest and they would say yeah put
on the Holland's I will show you your
dream kitchen the really cool part is it
doesn't stop here because there are
actually using voice recognition to see
they know what you're looking at so
you're looking at the doorknobs for
example you say oh those are ugly and
then they put and put that back into
their research and say we are so many
people thought the doorknobs were all
good ugly let's do something about that
so this works both ways I love that
example it's really really really cool
Case Western Reserve University you
actually use the space for for teaching
the human body you can walk around you
can see wherever thing is being from
Sweden
Volvo uses this and their flagship
stores
you can see actually see how the car
would look in different angles or colors
or something like that nASA uses this
and the really cool example called
destination Mars the thing is there the
experience is all about you're gonna be
standing on Mars we're really cool Buzz
Aldrin is is showing you rocks and stuff
like that on Mars look here this might
be evidence of water on Mars stuff like
that cool experience but there's a
problem the feel of you the objects are
well it's freaking Mars it's gonna be
huge right so you actually just gonna
see a little bit on Mars which is not a
good experience cool thing if you have
the if you have the opportunity
definitely try it but this should have
been a virtual reality experience
instead way better there's a game called
robber raid you might have seen it I
think it was wasn't a build but some
kind of big Microsoft event where the
demo disk so there's actually robots
coming out of the walls it's busting a
hole in your wall flying in and you can
shoot at them what they have done this
is a really good example of all the
things that I mentioned the robots are
smaller than you feel of you they're
gonna move quite slowly so you can you
can always there didn't so if the device
were actually has one problem one more
problem and if you move very fast it's
gonna be a little bit of trailing or
delay if you will it's really really
good and it when in regards to that
object is stationary but but the the
light emitters are not going to be
spot-on but they have the robots are
moving slowly so so you don't get that
and that effect it's a really fun game
as well I mean they're actually robust
busting through for when it comes to the
field of view we demoed this for for
like I think it's about 3,000 people's
buying by now and about 70 percent says
that yeah the field of you know sorry
some percents that doesn't even think
that the field of you is a problem
they're concentrating on there's robot
busting out of my wall and shooting at
me 30 percent says yeah can't work with
this so far I have not I think I've met
like one or two people that actually has
a hololens that thinks this is problem
because you adapt you step one step back
if the feel of you is too small I tried
one of the first games I tried was this
game fragments you're a memory detective
and it's all about finding a little
little kidnapped boy and what you can do
is here you can actually step in to his
memories fragments of his memories if
you will so you see on your wall at home
you see a couple of bricks
you see buckets standing on your floor
there's a raft running off all over the
floor and in one instance I look up and
I realized huh
has that hole always been in the roof
it's actually raining in from that hole
on to my actual coffee table building
small puddles and I hear a voice a voice
from one of my rights I'm in a
conference call they call it and there's
actually a game character sitting in my
couch relaxed as you do in the couch
because the homeless knows that's a
couch
and all these awesome technologies is
actually in the mixture of toolkits the
guys who developed this game has taken
all their knowledge put it in to turn to
the mixture I took it there I was gain
character sitting in my couch there is a
hole in my roof I have water damage all
over the floor it was so cool let's see
what it takes to actually implement
spatial mapping now this is going to be
a lot of information so we go up here go
to configure again apply mix Realty
scene settings and we're gonna add the
spatial mapping prefab and we're done
that is actually all it takes to create
what it actually does is that it's gonna
see the floor it's gonna create a mesh
on top of that and so so the tubes going
to land on the floor it's gonna have a
Collider out of the box
now this isn't that fun to actually look
at in in unity so I thought we should
try to actually connect up our hololens
see Microsoft
yes
hopefully this works as I said this is a
borrowed hololens
not yet
I do realize that this isn't fun to look
at
their ass
or perhaps it's fun to look at because
you kind of look like an idiot
there it is
now keep in mind you will see a lot of
lag but this is not my experience it's
it's the streaming thing that that
creates that so let's launch our app and
you see it all the shaking that is
actually micro vibrations in my head my
pulse for example so again this is
nothing that I actually see
so there's the cube can walk around it
it's going to be red if I look at it if
I tap on it it can become green and you
can see what the hololens actually sees
on the floor so if I say drop cube it's
actually going to land on the floor kind
of cool right let's go back
I actually had a backup video in case
that didn't work
so it's all about adding the spatial
mapping prefab now I mentioned my first
computer and I want to show you one of
my projects that I'm working on right
now so years ago I set out to build a
set expectrum emulator I wanted to see
if it was possible can I do this so I
bought a book I started page one so this
is the assembly instruction what is this
actually doing to the memory so in in
preparations of this talk I ported it to
unity so this is what it looks like so
this is actually a 3d model of a TV
standing on a table what you're probably
if you really quick I think you could
see my yeah there there I actually have
a gamepad using a gamepad and I
controlled the the little moon guy
astronauts to collect these items it's
it's apparently I mean this is was a
this was like 85 I believe I got this
computer and and this is actually pretty
tough for a computer to emulate it's
really really many instructions it's
really real a lot of CPU going on here
so I'm gonna end with a quote from
Terminator 2 there's no fun the future
isn't set there's no fate but what we
make for ourselves we're really really
early in the augmented reality space we
have a lot of things in front of us and
we do make the rules right now so you've
seen a lot of awesome experience as I
like I don't like to call them apps I
would like to call them experiences that
people have done or in my case
revisiting my past with that
nology of the future I guess so please
share your mouse popping moments with me
and one day in a not so distant future I
believe someone would start the
presentation kind of like this one but
they will ask do you remember your first
holographic computer thank you so much
[Applause]